Fear not, Mandalorian fans everyone's favorite
50-year-old infant will be on shelves in time
for Christmas, in some form or another.
Disney has announced that merchandise featuring
"The Child" — or, as viewers of the Disney+
series have affectionately nicknamed it, "Baby
Yoda" — will be on sale in the weeks leading
up to Christmas.
According to CNBC, the merch will include
"apparel and accessories," and while no specific
mention was made of plush toys… we simply
can't imagine that there won't be Baby Yoda
plush toys sitting under Christmas trees this
year, even if they might hit shelves a little
later in the holiday season.
In case you've been hiding under a rock since
The Mandalorian's debut, the Star Wars series
focuses on the titular bounty hunter, who
is tasked with bringing in a target that has
proven ridiculously difficult for members
of his nefarious Guild to get their scummy
hands on.
Said target is located under heavily armed
guard at a remote fortress on the harsh desert
planet of Arvala-7, and with the help of a
bounty hunting droid, IG-11, the Mandalorian
is able to nab it.
To his surprise, the target is a half-century
old, infant member of the same unnamed race
as the iconic Jedi Master Yoda.
Rather than allow IG-11 to terminate it, the
Mandalorian dispatches the droid — setting
off one of the oddest interplanetary buddy
adventures of all time.
The silent, contemplative, Force-sensitive
"Child" instantly captured the hearts and
minds of viewers, because it is — in a word
— adorable.
Its reveal at the conclusion of The Mandalorian's
debut episode was a heck of a surprise, so
it's no wonder that merch centered around
the floppy-eared tot wasn't made available
prior to its premiere.
But there's no way Disney didn't know the
extent to which the character would captivate
the series' viewers, so it seems pretty likely
that the House of Mouse will do its best to
make sure that under every household's tree,
a Baby Yoda there will be.
"This is what was causing all the fuss?"
Of course, Hasbro — which holds the license
to produce Star Wars toys — has had no comment
on when actual plush toys will be available.
In the informed opinion of one industry insider,
though, failing to exploit that market would
be akin to tearing up a license to print money.
Marissa DiBartolo, Editor-in-Chief of The
Toy Insider, told MarketWatch:
"As long as the merch hits before the holidays,
it's going to be a huge success.
If it drops before Black Friday, which we
expect it will, I guarantee it'll be gone
in an instant.
'Baby Yoda' will be the Tickle Me Elmo of
2019 just grab yours before it ends up on
eBay."
"No wonder he's laughing — all the way to
the bank — because North America has been
gripped by Tickle Me Elmo hysteria."
"Oh boy!
That tickles!"
It stands to reason that within a few months
at the most, you'll be able to pick up Baby
Yoda toys, mugs, hats, and probably anything
else you could conceive of at retail outlets
from department stores all the way down to
your local gas station.
In order to score some merch in time for the
holiday, though, you'll have to know where
to look.
In the weeks leading up to Christmas, you
may want to check department stores Target,
Kohl's, and Macy's, as well as specialty retailers
Zazzle, Hot Topic, and Box Lunch.
Also, some products will be available at the
Disney Store, on the website ShopDisney.com,
and at Disney Parks.
At this point, it's being reported that consumers
will be able to pre-order toys — including
those of the plush variety — over the coming
weeks.
It's unclear exactly what type of merchandise
is expected to ship in the coming weeks, but
again, we'd be shocked if Disney's goal wasn't
to get a plush Baby Yoda into the hands of
everybody who wants one by Christmas.
Now, there's always the chance that the Tickle
Me Elmo comparison could prove to be apt,
and that the demand for Baby Yoda toys over
the next month could far exceed the supply.
Given the cuddly critter's explosive popularity,
in fact, we find this to be pretty likely
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.